dès le 1er avril la salle du Jeu de
Paume de Versailles où vos ses portes au
public après une période de rénovation
ce site historique symbolique de la
Révolution française et berceau de la
République et la République française
avait un rendez-vous important le 10 et
23 avril 2022 face à la candidate du
rassemblement national et manuel Macron
est réélu en recueillant 58% des voix
dans les Yvelines le président de la
République devant largement Marine Le
Pen avec 71% des suffrages à noter
l'important taux d'abstention qui
atteint des niveaux historiques
l'histoire s'écrit aussi au FC
Versailles après une saison pleine les
footballeurs Versailles ont validé leur
montée en National à Saint-Malo c'est
une première pour le club quelques
semaines plus tard Versailles sera sacré
champion de National 2 après leur
victoire 1 à 0 face à Plabennec autre
événement sportif direction le vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
avec un tournoi international de Andy
tennis de table de Sky part à tt French
Open environ 380 plongistes venus de 33
pays ont pu concourir durant 4 jours du
5 au 8 mai l'événement se déroulait aux
Clayes-sous-Bois le geek-up festival à
rassemblé des personnages de manga du
monde médiéval ou encore des sorciers la
magie de la nature aux eaux de Thoiry
plusieurs naissances au sein du parc
animalier katluvetot cette bboyotes et
huit renardeaux une année exceptionnelle
qui permet de préserver des espèces
parfois menacées au chapitre éducation
le lycée franco-allemand de Buc fait
peau neuve des nouvelles salles
d'enseignement la reconstruction du
gymnase ou encore une toiture en forme
de parasol pour récupérer l'eau de pluie
des travaux qui permettent d'augmenter
les capacités d'accueil des élèves le
mois de juin a été marqué par le
troisième tour des présidentielles les
élections législatives dans les Yvelines
quatre nouveaux députés ont été élus car
l'olive et Charles Rodwell pour la
majorité présidentielle Benjamin Lucas
et William Martinet ont fait basculer
respectivement la et la 11ème
circonscription à gauche ces deux
parlementaires siègent dans le groupe de
la nupes les Yvelines à l'honneur au
sein du Palais Bourbon d'abord la
députée de la dixième circonscription
des Yvelines Aurore berger était lui
présidente du groupe parlementaire
Renaissance et Yaël Brown privé est élu
par les 577 députés de l'émission le
président de l'Assemblée nationale une
élection particulière pour livelinoise
qui devient la première femme à occuper
cette fonction dans l'histoire politique
française